you're a fortnight kid now the biggest
threat to suburban white teens in this
country is opioids close second
trampolines maybe someone just dared him
to rim himself I admire him for going
for it
well you bitch-ass parents are gonna
like to hear this but I think he would
have been fine if the net wasn't there
I've invented the safest way to enjoy
the deadly double bounce you can do it
anywhere except on a trampoline the only
requirement is that you respect the BB
c-- by saying
Boing BB C BB c BB C Boing so how's
everything taste of a b c BB c
[Music]
BB C bowling
BB C movie BB C
not since surprise trust Falls have I
created such a pointless sensation post
your own BB C vids and we'll send you
upwards of $100 upwards but most likely